how did you build that character what
were you basing it on and all that it
was so it was there on the page but
really like i read this
it was without like a lot of the
physicality but like it was it's like
okay he said it but jared
if you
sorry there was a funny moment just
before this if you want to note it while
you're in the bathroom
she can hear us it's a funny dick queef
thing that i think might be worth noting
and cutting everything else out
just all we really just a one minute
episode adds one minute of dick queef
more ads then it comes back to us and
we're just laughing about dick queef
dweef adewie now i just made that up i
knew you did we i yes handed it very
fast i'm a dweeb not a twin
um it was sort of on the page yeah
so it was yeah it was on the page but if
you knew it's i don't know if you've met
jared um
but he is like a master like he all the
characters he'll do himself and he's
this really animated guy and he's just
like the second he did the voice he's
just like well i picture him as this guy
who's just like
listen up flip an idiot i don't want to
do it and everything was a little bit
more lippy and a little bit more
exaggerated but it's still
i was like yes that's me and my younger
brothers yeah like whenever they're
pissed whenever they're annoyed that's
just that's them so i just like that's
it that's a boom everything this guy is
it's just this constantly
crapped on younger brother type who's
just like
oh
yeah just he's the sound he's that
through chapped lips yes
mouth breathing yeah kind of crusty kid
who thinks
dragons reality is too much yes yeah and
well the eye was kind of a weird mix of
just me
and i squint a lot and also just like
yeah we're shooting in the sun and
everything's and it's like you blocking
out the world he's just like too much
it's just
sorry i've been doing it now but it's
just like it was just it was natural for
me but it like made sense for the
character it was so easy yeah and
we just yes yeah and and jared and i i
will say we went to the d.i i don't know
if you like but in provo i like the
deseret industries that's their um
goodwill you know it's just where you
can go get secondhand uh clothing
everything so we went to the local di
and we just started going through
clothes and we just started like oh he'd
wear this kind of shirt this got a sweet
ninja or a sweet dragon on it with these
acid wash jeans and then simply it was
like he mentioned the moon boots i was
like sweet i remember having those
and then his wife
um was like
and this is the best part this is like a
day or so later after i said yes i'm
going to do this short which was a
two-day shoot and preston it was like no
big deal yeah
but
before that she's like called me up and
and because they they worked together
and did everything so jerusha his wife
she's like john what do you think about
a perm
i was like and i was single
and i was like
you know i was like okay i'm a post
mission i want to like start dating i'm
not good at dating i don't know how to
but i like girls and i want to get with
them and i don't think a perm is going
to help me
but all this
thought process
it's going to be harder everything i
just told you was a millisecond where i
thought that and then within the same
millisecond i was like
dude what who am i kidding
you're never going to see another
student
here who's not even officially an actor
i'm not a paid or a professional actor
but you're not going to see another
student do
make that kind of commitment for student
film and i saw what level jared was on
and he's going to give it a dissolve i
was like we are going to kill it like of
course yes and i was like yeah
absolutely let's get a perm
so
i got my friend who was a hairstylist
and she gave me the best perm
of your life that
ever that i have ever had but it was it
was tight it was amazing i still tell
people the perm in the short is
years better than the one in the film oh
really oh yeah it's so good because by
the time we shot the film
we had someone else do it they didn't
they did it wrong so we had to re-perm
which fried my hair is just a mess so
what happened between the short and it
becoming a feature i mean so we did the
short and it was awesome and we got it
in like slam dance which is like
sundance adjacent in the same place but
it's the smaller version yeah
and that was like that might have gotten
into a few other film festivals but the
point was is like this
short gotten this is a
to me it was perfection
um and people were digging it like the
local kind of indeed well the film scene
at byu like people got it they loved it
but you know i didn't know how far that
was going to go and it was like maybe i
don't know maybe a few months later that
jared calls me up and he's like dude
what do you think about doing a feature
next
was like the following summer so we shot
this in like fall of 2001
and then
2003 is when we shot the summer of 2003.
so he's like he had about a year and a
half like i want to shoot a feature
of this
what do you think i was like yeah of
course on the game like why would i say
no to that yeah and he originally he
what a lot of people don't know is like
he wanted it to be just the same kind of
vibe but different characters he knew
you wanted to call it napoleon dynamite
because the the the black and white the
short one my name is seth and there's no
he just knew he wanted his first female
i don't see seth dynamite making 44
million in the theaters or whatever yeah
and uh
that's a big mistake
seth isn't working no
cespadine was his name okay i like it
again i like that it was rad i was like
we kept i think svedine made it into the
film i didn't okay but
he was like he originally talked to me
was like what if we like shaved your
head and gave you braces and he was
thinking of a another crusty kid from
preston idaho
but wasn't the same but then we did the
sh oh and then that's right he had
talked to me before the short really
came out then after the short and he saw
how well it worked
and it was kind of a test that you know
a lot of directors would do that he's
like no we're keeping that character
yeah it works so well don't [__] with
seth yes and then let's we call him
napoleon dynamite news new name and then
we're just gonna where did that come
from so he on his mission
uh get out yeah he was on the streets in
chicago
came across this guy they start talking
about like
hey i'm elder hess he's like oh elder
jesse starts talking about like well
it's a title we go by this and he's
explaining the name so what's your name
and he's like because like that's
interesting you're talking about like
interesting names well mine is napoleon
dynamite shut up he was just like you
shut the [__] up when you're talking to
me he was this weird italian guy but get
this i don't know if a lot of this was
even crazier we found out later
that napoleon dynamite was
is like a pen name
that elvis costello used on one of his
albums
what
back in like i think it was like the 70s
or 80s so
i think this guy was a big fan of elvis
costello yeah or
knew someone who was a big fan it could
have been you know yes uh
hand-me-down through generations this
name
jared had no idea of that connection
he just like that is the sweetest name
i've ever heard i'm writing it down
because he knew he was going to be a
filmmaker he was like i'm going to make
my first film called napoleon dynamite
[Music]